muito bom dia a todos eu vou explicar
porque eu sou mais bonito do mundo o
mais fluentes e mais rico
espero que no final sejam hits futebol
o maior do mundo lá fora e nunca eu
gosto muito
o óleo é o dia em paris já era rico e
agora ae
então eu sou bonito
já sei quem quer vender o dia estava
melhor
vocês podem ser assim
amanhã a empresa e ver como é que eu vou
ficar em boa forma e fica encantado de
fazer uma coisa que diz que só faz 80
anos
o mesmo vai acontecer alguma coisa
quando vocês vão ser teletransportados
outra galáxia
vocês vão andar no tempo
as máquinas do tempo existem vocês não
tenham medo a maio foi atrás de você
mesmo em maio de 2005
alguns você pensou o perfume dirigidos a
joão e perguntei festa copos e
influentes mas alguns voz e pesaram na
profissão normal e beijing como se fosse
a primeira vez ea mãe como se não
houvesse amanhã
obrigado